foreign
Rob Kardashian resurfaces in a rare
family photo he's you know trying to
manage all the different things in his
life and you know be in a crazy family
with a hundred sisters and it's like
it's wild yeah
that's Rob posing it up with his mom
Grandma MJ MJ and sisters Chloe Courtney
and Kim at Chris's karaoke Birthday Bash
last year I don't know what's going to
top that and Rob he's all smiles this
year the theme was a bit different eras
of Chris
this is the thank you next Kris Jenner
amazing this is done daily question
yeah that's court giving us Chris in
Ariana Grande's thank you next music
video thank you next [ __ ] honestly I
don't know who did it best
[Music]
safe to say Chloe Courtney Kylie and Kim
understood the assignment it's never a
dull moment as for Rob the last time we
saw him on social media was back in July
while on vacay with his daughter dream
celebrating Coco's b-day
I know it's gonna be a good day oh yeah
Chloe shared that clip of her daughter
true Kim's daughter Chicago and dream
running around on Auntie Kylie's private
jet giving us a tiny glimpse of Rob
getting in on the fun it's a beautiful
thing Rob also posted a series of snaps
from the trip to his own page including
this one with his feet kicked up of
course Rob has opted to stay out of the
public eye in recent years he even
skipped Courtney's Italian wedding to
Travis Barker back in May and that trip
for Khloe's birthday marked the first
time Rob had been seen publicly since
his family won the defamation lawsuit
filed by dream's Mom his ex Blac Chyna
in May as a mom I'm very protective of
my kids and on top of that it's really
draining it's emotionally physically and
spiritually exhausting to be going
through this I really don't want to add
to the the drama and while Rob has
seemingly put all that drama behind him
fans of the famous family will get a
behind the scenes look at the trial on
the fam's Hulu reality show the
Kardashians the mother of my brother's
daughter is suing me Kylie Kimberly and
my mom for defamation and interference
with the contract she is saying that the
Rob and China show
didn't get a second season because we
interfered with it not because they
weren't in a relationship anymore
foreign